he's up for re-election next year do you
think there's enough time and enough of
strategy that the republicans can put
together to have any hope for next
november any okay so if they do if they
do who's gonna come and campaign for the
guy
okay give me give me five names so by
the way let me ask a question a
different way let me ask a question a
different way let me ask a question a
different way
give me
ten names from the left that are willing
to go and campaign for anybody in any
estate for it to flip to be a blue state
give me ten names come along look how
long it'll take you go okay kamala you
got um pelosi if she can get on a plane
obama uh probably hillary
uh
by bernie aoc
bernie aoc
the michigan governor you name anybody
yeah
newsome anybody because they're that
united well i think they're united now
when they get 350 trillion dollars into
their unions and their power that entire
infrastructure bill
pay them through 3.5 trillion they're
only they're only just getting started
so so but now well you were going
somewhere with this you're gonna right
your follow-up is what republicans would
do that they're not gonna do that they
don't have the money
listen mitch mcconnell this is this is a
problem the problem is
that one side is all about the
collective
the other side is all about the
individual this is why i believe center
right is the right place to be and the
only reason is center right is because
the right fiscally you cannot debate
capitalism i don't want to hear any
argument against capitalism i don't care
if you your feelings got hurt because
you lost to somebody else because they
put in more effort than you did
capitalism works the only type of
capitalism that doesn't work is crony
capitalism and nobody wants crony
capitals except the people at the top
that are willing to buy that fine some
of them are doing that no problem and by
the way if you got rid of lobbyists a
lot of [ __ ] will change in capitalism if
you actually eliminated the concept of
lobbying a lot of things would change
but let me let me take a different angle
for you let me take a different angle
for you go back 12 months ago
uh 12 months no go back 13 months ago 14
months ago
who's a hero on tv every day this are
the cuomo's faucets
these guys were heroes okay they were
heroes if you thought about it texas
florida you guys are irresponsible et
cetera et cetera still doing that with
florida fast forward fast forward to six
months ago who became an enemy of the
left on the left who cuomo como yeah how
quickly did they take this guy from the
next potential president
to this guy's got to get the hell out of
here
he cut them off as fast they could you
think he's the first person that has
stories like that as fast as he said
we're not shutting down new york by the
way he's a tie and he talks with his
video let me ask you a question who had
a worse story up into being a governor
and wanting to run for president bill
clinton or cuomo
bill it's not even is it is it fair to
say it's not even close it's likely not
it's not even close okay so now watch
this now watch this
so let's put two people against each
other let's put three people against
each other you ready i love you let's
put a game let's put a guy named cuomo
in there andrew yeah let's put a guy
named newsome in there let's put a guy
named mansion in there yeah between
those three who is most likely willing
to say yes to anything their political
party tells them to do just to be able
to get a nicer fatter title i'd say
my god i agree which one's the least
like
i would actually tell you it's both of
them i would have
i actually think it's like mansion wins
by 52 to 48 but it's not a big
difference yeah i don't see cuomo as a
yes guy nor do i see manchin as a yes
guy certainly not now angry as hell the
most marketable people on the left are
those that say yes newsom is a yes guy
cuomo's clearly not a no guy
he is a yes guy okay meaning newsome is
a yes guy they got a guy that they're
going to market fyi you may have just
seen your future president i think that
you have just so you know here's the
question do you think more on his
do you think he's obsessed listen all
you have to know crazy all you have to
know is who's ma who's better him or
biden as a president him him but naming
one thing newsome's done it doesn't
matter
exactly what question did you just ask
gerard you're you're very intellectual i
understand what you're saying but you
can't you have to be able to name one
thing
wait wait wait he looks the part what
has what did obama do one term guy he
would yeah well he was a great speaker
i've heard gavin newsom speak he's not
obamacare
and he's a very
very well put together good looking yes
he looks like hey that's why he's the
sexy voice i'm sorry he's extremely
marvelous he looks like christian bale
in american psychology he's doing so
much worried about this he's got to go
return to the video easily
he is all that's why he was so worried
because he thought this would get the
express train off the rails as far as
the only thing that matters for him is
to be president like with jesus
jack just gave 50 bucks he says let's
have adam live in new york city or l.a
for six months his position on many
things will change adam you're a smart
guy wake up bro no way
those votes count as legit even liberals
don't want their kids exposed to all the
trashy people on their city streets
anyways okay can i validate one point
you made though when you had that
tipping point right as far as like for
me i think if you're not booking your
ticket out of california and you love
california you love la you're at least
considering what it's going to be
because it what what is inevitable that
would pull the trigger and i know what
it is for me if homelessness comes into
manhattan beach
if that happens i'll see you guys within
a week let me tell you this you asked
about strategy and this is the strategy
right in any particular situation all
right you have two binary options as
your immediate options you have fight or
you have flight and if you are not going
to commit to the fight if you are not
going to rally the troops and you are
not going to get a war chest together
get out of there
go to a place consolidate your
well-being this is why i keep telling
all my friends and family new york
philadelphia uh staten island long
island uh brooklyn a leaf let them have
it they won
give it to them there's no reason that
your life should be ruined there's no
reason that the hours of your life
should pay for what they want come down
to a place that has your world view i'm
going to tell you
moving to florida was like guys in new
york do not listen to gerard stay the
hell in new york we don't want you in
florida and then what will happen is let
the weight of their programs hollow them
out let them die on the vine and then go
back and pick up the pieces let they
want to be detroit be detroit they want
to be moscow be moscow come down live
your life and then go back here's
here's a
the level of strategy on one side is so
much better than the other side you know
how easy it is to be the team that's
divided just think about it this way
here's what you got to think about go to
the laker squad where it's kobe
it's shaq it's malone it's peyton it's
rod i mean go who was on that squad
everybody and their mothers was mush
parker everybody was on that squad but
you know what they were they were
divided they couldn't stand their
parents with each other
they were just absolute highest level of
hatred phil left it was so ugly nobody
could keep that team together right
what happened to them did they win the
championship no on paper on paper if you
go take any video game you put that
squad together match them up against
anybody seven game series who beats them
nobody yeah no as a team team not as you
make your own team like michael lebron
you put everybody on the same team the
republicans have so much talent right
now they got a great squad but you are
not united you're not going to beat
anybody it's just that simple you're
just not going to beat everybody not in
california
it doesn't matter it's it's but but
here's the other part let me give you
the other part that's what's happening
uh
when when policies on your own political
side start making no sense
a kid will even question his own father
and mother
just like a part a individual will
question their own individual party if a
kid would how many times did you
question your mom or dad's decision
often okay how by the way
how many times do you think they're
going to question my decision as they
grow your kids yeah they'll still
probably of course they're going to of
course they're going to my son has
already done it tico is under multiple
so has dylan how long did you ground him
no he didn't get grounded i actually i
don't mind the conversations like that
but here's the point
the voters right now what is happening
is they're simply sitting there some of
them are saying listen man i don't mind
being a freaking democrat no i don't
mind being this but some of this [ __ ]
just doesn't make any sense am i the
only one that's thinking this way some
of this stuff just doesn't make sense
that's when it gets weird because adam
as much as you're sitting here saying
what you're saying
you wouldn't survive in california or
new york today you wouldn't be able to
do it
you wouldn't be able to live so i live
in florida but what i'm trying to tell
you is
he's first-hand
i lived there five and a half years ago
so i'm first hand but five and a half
years ago it's not the same california
today as it was five and a half years
ago six years ago so very different
california right if you go there today
than what it was five and a half years
ago people are feeling the pain now what
will happen with this part here what's
gonna happen here this is what i'm
hoping this is what i'm hoping today i
was into rio sal romano
sal romano was uh the former mobs wall
street guy this guy embezzled they were
embezzling 10 billion per year not from
the stock market he had one point was
worth 300 million dollars salary for the
gambino family he did stuff with mickey
scars from the guy he did a bunch of
different things that this guy said
oh he did time yeah but sal romano was
he was literally sitting where adam is
sitting here right now he left about 30
minutes ago 45 minutes ago to be exact
30 minutes ago 45 minutes goes where he
left right and we're sitting there
having a conversation together
there comes a time where you can no
longer tolerate what's going on and
you're eventually going to flip so he's
sitting there telling the stories of
well you know eventually everybody flips
why does eventually everybody flip in
the mob world well because of this
because of that because of this okay
if
i back you up and you continuously
backstab me what am i loyal to
so if i give you my vote and you're
constantly abusing my vote you don't
think certain parties are sitting there
saying why the hell am i voting this way
for the longest and blacks voted
republican martin luther king was a
registered republican
what happened when they were registered
republican shows up a guy named barry
goldwater right then what happens i'm
sorry it all flipped the parties flip by
the way not by a little bit yeah it went
from 60 to 92 percent of
african-americans voting democrat like
this how many how many african-american
grandmothers do you know that all they
talk about is the bible how many k how
many friends did you have had a bunch of
friends that was growing up all their if
i saw their mom or grandma everything
was about the bible bible bible bible
more than armenians whites or
more than any other it was always the
bible that's a conservative belief what
happens
hey republicans you did this barry
goldwater no problem so
you know as much as i think california
is not going to flip for four to eight
years i think it's going to stay that
way i don't think this stays like that
for 20 years so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you